تصدر البرنامج السعودي استديو 23 الذي
يعرض على ام بي سي ومنصه شاهد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي كافه بعد ان تم تقليد
الامير هاري وزوجته ماجن والاعلاميه
اوبراير في اطار ساخر وهو يصدق على كل ما
تقوله فيما تتجاهله وتكتفي بالحديث مع
زوجته خالد الفراج هو من قام بدور الامير
هاري نتابع
[موسيقى]
بس للتصحيح
اوكي اوكي
وش حكايه الخاتم اللي في يده ميجا
تلمي
الخاتم هذا كان حق امه
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مشاهد
للتناول للافطار وتاديه الاف للمصلين
لصلاه التراويح في ساحه تايم سكوير
بنيويورك الامريكيه للسنه الثانيه على
التوالي
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
[موسيقى]
نستبدل الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
الين
سؤال يطرحه رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
من اين
ظهر هذا الرجل مقطع فيديو انتشر لظهور
مفاجئ لشاب بعد اصطدام دراجه ناريه بسياره
اجره على جانب احد الشوارب بمدينه بوكار
شمال كولومبيا ما اثار الاستغراب
والتكهنات
[موسيقى]
نشر الرائد الفضاء الاماراتي سلطان
النيادي مقطع فيديو للقاهره حيث بدات بدات
مضيئه ومنيره وكانها حبات من الالماس وذلك
اثناء وجوده في محطه الفضاء الدوليه معلقا
تحيه الى مصر تحيه الى ام الدنيا وعاصمتها
القاهره نشاهد
من محطه خضار الدوليه
وحابه اشارككم هذا المرور الليلي فوق
الجمهوريه مصر العربيه
وبالتحديد
القاهره
نسوي زوم على القاهره من الفضاء
مثل ما تشوفون الدلتا ماخذه
شكل الورده
[موسيقى]
فهذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء